alte leute gebt euch das ein indoor
golfplatz ein teppich ach so auch nicht
okay leute ich bin soweit fertig so
sieht's jetzt aus das meisterwerk
hey was geht ab und herzlich willkommen
zu einem neuen video leute ich hab
natürlich geht es gut ich habe heute was
wirklich interessantes vor
und zwar habe ich eine neue seite
gefunden und diese seite hat es in sich
und ich dachte mir da muss ich ein video
machen wo wir die praktisch zusammen so
ein bisschen erforschen das ist halt
wirklich an sich sondern komplette
herrlich soll ich sagen allein der titel
schon shut up and take my money so
nettig dieser seite starb an take my
money punkt kommt wirklich seriös klingt
das ja nicht aber es ist mal was neues
und ich denke so ist es halt so was ja
so sondern moderne seite so ein modernes
vielleicht das falsche wort keine ahnung
also ich denke auch nicht dass da
irgendwie so meine eltern bestellen
würden aber ich definitiv
und das machen wir heute wir suchen uns
ein paar produkte raus die welt stammen
bestellen und im video testen
ich muss allerdings vorweg sagen es ist
nicht leicht jedes produkt zu bekommen
da manche sachen aus amerika kommen auf
manche shops habe ich so keinen zugriff
hat sich nach deutschland liefern also
das wird ziemlich kompliziert ich bin
mir aber sicher dass wir das eine oder
andere wirklich coole produkt finden was
wir zu 100 prozent noch nicht gesehen
habt in eurem leben wie zum beispiel
diesen extrem neiße nach sodass ich
glaube ich den rest lande auf jeden fall
ist das im scheibenwischer
ja es ist einfach komplett verrückt
stelle ich vorher zu dem scheibenwischer
und hier liegt dann so ein wrestler und
dieser wrestler geht die ganze zeit also
drauf geil
der ist zum beispiel nach deutschland
nicht verfügbar habe ich ich hoffe dass
ich das irgendwie hinkriege werdet ihr
gleich sehen so dann schauen wir uns
erstmal hier die startseite haben wie
scrollen mal ein bisschen runter und da
geht es eigentlich auch schon los also
wir haben wirklich viele produkte die
auch zum teil sehr teuer sind hier ist
275 euro oder so geht es jetzt an sich
nur scheiße weil wobei ich diese wand
alle was ist das leid saber wall mount
alte okay ach guck mal die kanzlerin
wahrscheinlich in allen verschiedenen
farben stellen gar nicht mal so übel
aber wir gehen einfach mal hier in die
kategorien es gibt ja ganz viel wir
gehen einfach mal kommen rom start
nochmal ganz klar
und schauen was war da so finden ich
habe natürlich eben auch schon mal so
reingeguckt was mich wirklich extrem
umgehauen hat ist hier diese penis
kaktus vorhängen plenter oder was auch
genial ist diese nuklear explosion laut
lempp das ist eine lampe alter oder
diese lampe so was habe ich noch nie
gesehen in seinem leben spaceship lamb
von match.com okay gut die gibt es auch
auf amazon die könnte hierhin bestellen
kann halt nicht alles über die seite
bestellen dann müsst ihr mir nicht übel
nehmen aber die seite sorgt für
unfassbar geniale inspiration und hier
ist halt wirklich hier gibt es an sich
kein müll drauf sowie bayerisch oder
irgendwie diesen ganzen anderen
plattform sondern jedes produkt hat es
irgendwie in sich finde ich zumindest
gut jedes ist jetzt auch übertrieben
oder alter leute gebt euch das ein
indoor golfplatz ein teppich ach so ist
halt nur ein bisschen teuer 399 dollar
und auch ein bisschen groß für mein
kleines zimmer hat sich jetzt muss schon
mal eine eigene wohnung
man gibt sogar verschiedene ausführungen
davon auch kein habe ich so noch nie
gesehen
oh mein gott einfach ein xbox controller
tisch das ist ja das ist so genial gibt
euch das 1000 dollar aber wenn du xbox
fan bist und zu viel geld hast dass du
einfach der über schütz naja ist mir
leider auch zu teuer sonst würde ich
jetzt bestellen gerne wir eine joschi 1
lampe auch cool wir gehen einfach mal
eine kategorie weiter rom und kitchen da
habe ich eben auch meisten sachen
gefunden so was zum beispiel so eine
ganz also das ist alles glas hier und da
kannst du dann einen whisky reihen
füllen oder dieses genau das produkt
leute das ist
self wie toaster ihr könnt dann foto von
euch rein legen und dann wird dieses
foto auf autos gemacht
ohne scheiß ich würde so abfeiern wenn
ich mir jeden morgen meint urs mache und
das selber drauf bin
wie geil wer das und es kostet an sich
sowie nur 75 dollar das ding wollte ich
eben wirklich schon bestellen ich habe
es allerdings nicht gefunden es ist
unmöglich dass nach deutschland zu
kriegen weil sie eine adresse habe wo
man das heer krieg schicken wir mal und
am besten auch unter 200 euro
was wirklich auf jeden fall absolut
neues mittelfinger whisky und hier ein
ein zelt für eine katze oder dass ihr
flying spaghettimonster schlüssel
pokemon poker set für cornflakes auch
nicht schlecht wir gehen mal in die
kategorie game das klingt doch gut
gaming ist immer noch was werden wir
dann hier zu finden ein pokal grenda für
die die nicht wissen was das ist ist
auch bessere alter hier ist nur so eine
leuchtende flasche coca cola mitleid
auch nice alter bisasam als topf den
will ich habe früher so pokémon gesucht
wird wie sesam blumentopf es gibt es
auch man aber es gibt nicht in den nicht
haben will man das sind alles dann so
bilde ausführungen die man hier hin
bestellen kann komma wie nice das
aussieht oder ist das ein bisschen
verkauf ort night lama sparschwein er
hat für die ganzen fordert kinder unter
euch das ist sowas gedacht komm wir
gehen wir mal auf gibt es vorhin was
kann man mir dann schenken also was ich
eben schon gesagt habe die produkte wir
sind alle ziemlich teuer das muss man
ganz klar sagen und in den kategorien
treten zum teil auch die gleichen
produkte auf darth vader barbecue grill
724 euro eine sache die ich eben schon
gefunden habe die ich gerne bestellen
würde ist dieser unfassbaren beer pong
pool table also du kannst dich entspannt
in pulling und gegen einen freund oder
kollegen beer pong spielen oder diese
glauben sagt beer pong becher auch nice
wobei ich nicht weiß ob ich die
hinkriegt also das ist zeit gibt es auf
jeden fall auch genau die kategorie weil
ich ab checken unter 25 dollar da gibt
es auf jeden fall eine menge was ich
bestellen kann alter waffen munition aus
schokolade ich frage mich was sie die
ganze zeit mit diesen pimmel nie haben
aber wer bitte leute unschwer bestellt
sich dann so was
ein penis ventil für sein auto warum
denn so was gibt es in deutschland zum
glück nicht
das ist und es leuchtet sogar ja klar
wobei ich das auch wirklich cool finde
eine bade bombe als jacob und der
absolute burner ist natürlich das hier
könnte ich für marie bestellen soll ich
das machen leute bei 5000 reichsmark das
für nächsten part weil ich bin mir
sicher es wird noch einiges von dieser
website geben weil wir nämlich so umhaut
es ist ja mir gefällt es jetzt schon
deutlich besser als frisch also ich
glaube ihr habt einen ziemlich guten
eindruck bekommen was es hier so viele
produkte gibt ich werde mir jetzt die
lustigsten und coolsten raussuchen die
ich von da bestellen kann hier hin und
für euch ist es nur eine sekunde für
mich wahrscheinlich mehrere tage bis ich
das alles hier habt und euch das zeigen
kann ok gut ich mache jetzt eine pause
und wir sehen uns sofort wieder
abonniert auf jeden fall bis dahin alle
fleißigen kanal weil es lohnt sich und
biss gleiche was geht ab ich hoffe ihr
seid noch franken blieben einige zeit
ist vergangen für euch nicht für mich
schon also es hat ein bisschen was
gedauert
ein paar produkte sind da ich hab noch
mehr bestellt allerdings habe ich mir
gedacht du kannst jetzt auch mit diesen
produkten die da sind schon mal das
video machen und wenn ihr dann sagt
gestell auf jeden fall noch mehr über
die seite lasst dann nach oben das
schreibt es in die kommentare
ob euch die seite gefällt und ob sich
das eurer meinung nach lohnt also ich
hab halt einfach irgendwelche sachen
gekauft an die ich irgendwie gekommen
bin und ich ja ein hoher einfach mal
raus leute als erstes haben wir hier
ich wusste nicht dass es sowas wird
allerdings bin ich jetzt auch nicht so
die person die das unbedingt braucht
weil ich habe keinen eigenen tun
allerdings wenn man im pool im garten
hat kann das schon hilfreich sein glaube
ich hatte mal hier kann man es gut sehen
man kann halt praktisch sind schwimmen
und sein getränk neben sich haben so zu
sagen ich bin da halt so ein bisschen
skeptisch auf das reibungslos
funktioniert hier von diesen dingern
sind dabei ach so ok und dann tut man
das so wahrscheinlich ins wasser man
kann dann sein getränk traum stellen ich
habe das ganze natürlich schon mal ein
bisschen vorbereitet und jetzt hier
keinen swimmingpool mit in meinem zimmer
genommen sondern einfach ein eimer
wasser keine angst ich filme gleich mal
hier rein
macht ja ich weiss meldungen aber ich
bin eigentlich eigentlich hätte ich
gedacht dass das auch so geht ich muss
wohl erst jetzt nur dose holen oder ein
glas und ich hatte auch hier alles wir
haben hier eine dose havanna cola keine
ahnung warum die hier in meinem zimmer
steht ab und jetzt könnte ich die
eigentlich hier reinstellen
jetzt ist da zu wenig wasser drin halte
ich dreh ab moment ich bin gleich wieder
da also ich weiß nicht ob ich irgendwas
verhalten kann eigentlich nicht das
muster funktionieren aber die dose geht
halt komplett unter also das ist viel zu
schwach deswegen fühlen wir mal ein
bisschen raus
oh ja wohl eine sauerei hier und jetzt
schauen wir mal ob es jetzt geht okay
jetzt funktioniert die zu hause hätte
jemand seine tage die leute hier kann
man es jetzt sehen wunderschön oder also
die colaflasche schwimmt jetzt jetzt bin
ich aber mal gespannt ob das auch noch
mit dem glas hier funktioniert also
dieser tropfen hier da ist echt richtig
bombenfest das ist ja schon mal gut und
glas wein wahrscheinlich ist dass nach
dass dieses viel zu schwer
also man kann glaube ich nur so maximal
100 milliliter einer dose hält das auch
sonst geht es um fragt habe jetzt noch
eine andere dose dies leer und das wird
auch ganz normal ja das funktioniert der
esi stimmt dann nehmen wir hier immer
noch die bierflasche und die geht halt
wieder komplett und also eigentlich ist
es kompletter müll kann man nichts mit
anfangen oder du trinkst nur 100
milliliter im pool
naja wir kommen wir ganz schnell zum
rasch jetzt muss ich vorsichtig sein
dass hier nicht nächsten produkt als ich
mir die seite angeschaut habe ich ja
glaube ich schon gesagt dass ich so eine
lampe bestellen möchte
sonst werde ich euch natürlich hier
gerne auch mal das produkt ein bisschen
was jetzt hier ist nicht schlimm
wir machen das mal auf ich habe mir dass
das sieht halt auf dem produkt modus
immer so viel größer aus
das ist so klein weiß ich nicht dass er
30 euro kostet oder sogar mehr als heißt
das wenn sich so vorstellung was
realität ist hier einfach so krass und
bewegen wollen die hier nicht verarschen
ich dachte es mindestens zu hoch oder so
das war halt auf den bildern wirklich so
geil aus warum sollte ich sonst so eine
raumschiffe bestellen aber wir testen
das jetzt mal müsste eigentlich jeden
moment angehen wow 30 euro na ja wir
machen einmal kurz hier das licht aus
gut jetzt hier im dunkeln kann ich sagen
kommt eigentlich sogar schon nice rüber
vielleicht müsste das hier oben so ein
bisschen leuchten für kinder die so
raumschiff vermögen kann man das
vielleicht empfehlen aber sonst hätte
ich da jetzt keine verwendung für kein
problem wir haben nämlich noch ein
produkt und das ist folgendes da freue
ich mich drauf jetzt wird es wirklich
genial
ich habe euch das am anfang des videos
gezeigt oder habe ich es gefunden das
war darauf direkt das erste produkt und
zwar dieser wrestler der halt dann so
als scheibenwischer agiert und die ganze
halle auf den anderen rest also drauf
geht
und deswegen habe ich den wrestler gab's
leider nicht aber ich habe noch etwas
cooles gefunden bisschen brutaler auch
sogar oder sind sogar machen wir sind
das verschiedene ich kann mir absolut
nicht vorstellen wie das live aussieht
weil ich hab so was auch noch nie an
einem auto gesehen ist natürlich auch
besser so ach also das gibt es auch noch
als nikolaus und als weihnachtsmann noch
co kg ist das glaube ich und mein
schneemann
ja das ist ja lange hier haben wir
diesen brutalen killer der dann dieses
messer auch hier perfekt also ich mach
das einfach mal dran und ich sage meine
eltern nichts weil ich habe ja muss
sagen und da kann man es nicht dran
machen weil ich habe hinten gar keinen
scheiben geschafft aber meine eltern
haben wir also wir gehen mal kurz runter
das bleibt okay leute ich bin jetzt
unten hier ist jetzt das auto von meinen
eltern mein auto hat wie gesagt kein
scheibenwischer hinten deswegen ich
schau jetzt mal wie ich das dran krieg
weil eben ein bisschen ich weiß noch
nicht so ganz welches system dahinter
steckt also eigentlich wäre dass man
hier noch drin wäre jetzt mal kurz ein
schlüssel okay leute ich bin soweit
fertig so sieht es jetzt aus das
meisterwerk und jetzt schmeißen wir den
ganzen laden hier mal angefragt was bei
denen ich mache das ja keinen hinten
lässt sich ein chemischer
wie das wissen ein herr das ist geil
okay vielleicht auch letztlich macht
wieder ab weil ich glaube so kann es ja
nicht rumfahren das geht schnell
wir machen weiter tja leute ich weiß das
war jetzt nur drei produkte mehr habe
ich leider noch nicht ich bin dass das
wochenende über in münchen weswegen ich
auch nicht warten kann und trotzdem
gerne schon mal die sache hier zeigen
wollte ihr könnt mir war ein coole
sachen schicken auch wenn irgendwas auf
der seite gesehen habe wohl sagt alexis
musst du auf jeden fall testen und
schickt mir das gerne auf install als
ich alex wie und wir sehen uns hier
nächste woche wieder gibt's neues video
abonniert auf jeden fall alle fleißigen
kanal daumen nach oben wäre super
leistung ein